looks like fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't think he's we know he's dead but
we didn't kill him he liked you're
afraid of murder or whatever okay the
guys here mr. ron ron lolani the girls
team taxi Leilani he's running to know
kind of so like she's wearing heels that
look actually
we have to go to the place because we
have nothing to hide you wash your rent
from the scene of the crime
good question officer that's me covering
up my body cam so I can be worse so we
just need to find the guy but police are
looking for do you suggest we actually
go out there and follow up murder
blocked did you think it was one of
those men only doors all we need is a
name and then we're in the clear
hey man it's been a minute [ __ ] yeah
who are you work for you little [ __ ]
you don't bean bag ball this [ __ ] yeah
if you think on your grandma on that for
a bean bag [ __ ] what these people are
super dangerous and they're really
powerful
their system Handmaid's Tale [ __ ]
we have imposters oh no imposters that
sucks
everyone unmask yourself oh sure nobody
else took that mask
I'm gonna give you lovebirds choice
what's behind this door or Bank and
grace to the fight I don't want grace on
my bias is it gonna [ __ ] on me
[Music]